martians might really exist in the
future but instead of the aliens of
sci-fi movies martians would be humans
born and raised on Mars and in this
episode you're one of
them why would your skin be
orange would you be a different species
and would you ever be able to visit
Earth this is what if and here's what
would happen if you were born on
Mars some of our previous episodes have
already looked at what it would take to
live on Mars but that's only half the
story to create a stable settlement on
the red planet people would have to
start having babies how many people
would we need to create a healthy on
inbred
population well some say we'd only need
98 people but others say we'd need a
minimum of
10,000 but regardless of the size of the
breeding population it would only take a
few Generations before we started seeing
a huge difference between earthlings and
martians Mars is the most earthlike
planet in the solar system but it's not
exactly like the Earth
its gravity atmosphere and magnetic
field would create serious challenges
for human life and challenges often go
hand inand with
Evolution children on Earth are born
with up to 120 genetic mutations move
those babies to Mars and they would
start having mutations suitable for
Martian living and those mutations would
likely pass on to their children by the
time we settle on Mars we'll probably
have the ability to modify our own genes
putting Martian Evolution on the fast
track so if you were born in the third
or fourth generation of martians you
would be a lot different than you are
today but what are the main reasons why
your body would
change well first there's gravity Mars
only has onethird of Earth gravity so
your bones wouldn't experience the same
force your bones would lose their
density and become more brittle breaking
them would become a common issue then
there's the atmosphere on Earth you're
used to a dense atmosphere that mostly
contains nitrogen and oxygen but on Mars
you'd be experiencing a thin atmosphere
that's mostly carbon dioxide with only
Trace Amounts of oxygen you wouldn't be
able to evolve a whole new respiratory
system but you could develop other ways
of dealing with the lack of oxygen like
you could have denser capillaries that
are more efficient at moving blood and
transporting oxygen to your muscles but
even with these advances you'd still
have to live underground or in a thickly
insulated house to survive the harsh
atmosphere and since Life on Mars would
be confined to small spaces Martians
wouldn't need to be able to see far into
the
distance yeah you would be born
nearsighted and finally there's the
radiation Earth has a strong magnetic
field that protects us from lethal solar
radiation but Mars has a weak magnetic
field that's scattered along the planet
on Earth our bodies produce melanin it
protects us from the radiation that does
make it through Earth's magnetic field
but the radiation on Mars would be much
stronger and melanin just wouldn't cut
it instead your skin would produce
carotenoids this pigment would help
protect you against skin cancer by
slowing or stopping the cell cycle
carotenoids can even make melanoma cells
self-destruct they're also what gives
carrots their vivid orange coloring yeah
in other words your skin would be
orange so with all these changes to your
body would you be able to visit
Earth well Mars wouldn't have the same
type of bacteria and viruses that the
Earth does so your immune system would
be weaker than that of an earthlings
which means Earth could be a dangerous
place for you and even if your immune
system were strong the gravity of Earth
would be too much for your brittle bones
if you were born on Mars you'd probably
have to stay
there humans have looked the same for a
very long time but within a few
generations of living on Mars we could
have orange nearsighted humans who could
survive on less oxygen and once we
successfully settle on Mars we probably
wouldn't stop there in the future humans
could have settlements on all sorts of
planets even outside the solar syst
system when it comes to planets in our
Solar System's habitable zone one world
is too close to the Sun another is too
far and Earth is just
right but maybe things would be
different if Venus and Mars simply
swapped
orbits what makes these planets
impossible to live on right
now what changes would they undergo when
they traded PL
places and why would you need Jupiter to
give these planets a chance at
supporting
life this is what if and here's what
would happen if Venus and Mars swapped
orbits our Solar System's habitable zone
otherwise known as the Goldilocks zone
is the distance from a star where liquid
water could exist on the surface of a
planet as long as conditions aren't too
hot or too cold life could be possible
just like on Earth but simply occupying
Prime real estate in the habitable zone
isn't a guarantee that a rocky planet is
actually habitable both Venus and Mars
orbit within this region too and yet no
life despite being of a similar size and
with roughly the same surface gravity as
Earth Venus is too hot to hold C liquid
water and dense its atmosphere is 90
times denser than our own and the
surface temperature is a scorching
462 de
C on the other end of the goldilock Zone
Mars is also quite earthlike except way
colder drier and
dustier its average surface temperature
is- 46 de C and it has an atmosphere
about 1% as thick as Earth's so if we
swapped things around would Venus and
Mars transform themselves into perfectly
livable
planets bringing the red planet into
Venus's orbit would put it at a distance
of approximately
108 million km from the Sun this would
bring it halfway closer to the Sun than
it was before being so much closer Mars
would get a significant boost in the
amount of sunlight it receives and that
alone can make the surface temperature
climb to a balmy 32° C just like the
Earth's Tropics but without a thick
atmosphere or oceans all this new heat
wouldn't stay on the planet just like in
Earth's deserts Mars would see extreme
temperature differences between day and
night the thin Martian atmosphere would
make it difficult for water to stay
liquid with such a low surface pressure
water would boil at a lower temperature
evaporation would happen much
quicker looks like if you want to see
life flourish on Mars you'd have to take
a slightly more Hands-On approach but
first let's check out how Venus is doing
in its new neck of the woods you'd Now
find Venus located
228 million km away from the Sun that's
twice as far as it used to be and
naturally you'd think surely this
scorching Planet would be starting to
cool down well as it turns out the
planet's high surface temperatures have
a lot more to do with its thick
atmosphere than its overall closeness to
the sun Venus has a very high albo which
means that it reflects about 75% of the
incoming sunlight so it could be that
the planet's temperature remains more or
less just as hot as before even as the
upper parts of the atmosphere slowly
cool enough for the alido effect to
decrease that would mean that Venus
could now absorb a larger amount of
incoming sunlight so that temperature
wouldn't start to drop all that
much another setback on the road to
becoming a life supporting Planet would
be that Venus's atmosphere is mostly
comprised of carbon dioxide with small
amounts of nitrogen and clouds of
sulfuric acid what you still wouldn't
find nearly enough of is water the
concentration of water in Venus's
atmosphere is 100 times too low for even
the most resilient organisms back on
Earth to
survive but since you went through all
the effort of bringing both planets from
one end of the habitable zone to the
other why not take things a little
further you could try terraforming the
planets to make them a little more
livable one way you could increase the
surface pressure of Mars would be to try
releasing all the carbon dioxide found
in its soil and minerals the only
problem here is that the red planet
would need to reach temperatures above
300°
C and despite this new location so close
to the Sun Mars would never get this
hot besides if you could release all of
that precious greenhouse gas it would
only amount to an atmospheric pressure
of about 10 to 14% of Earth's there
simply isn't enough carbon dioxide on
the red planet even if you had been
successful with that effort you'd still
be unable to breathe on Mars one option
for dealing with this would involve
bringing special microorganisms to the
planet that could convert the Hostile
Martian atmosphere into breathable
air this would be similar to what Earth
was like 2 and A2 billion years ago back
then cyanobacteria converted our methane
and ammonia-rich atmosphere into the
oxygen rich one you enjoy
today but ultimately this would be a big
waste of time and resources you'd find
that with Mars's weak magnetic field it
wouldn't be able to hold on to any
atmosphere you could create that would
be thanks to the power of solar winds
that would constantly strip away
whatever atmosphere you'd manage to
generate and sitting in Venus's old
orbit solar winds would be almost five
times as dense as Mars is used to way
out on Venus the question of creating
condition for life could come down to
whether you could manage to form an
ocean on the planet and that would
entail bombarding the atmosphere with
hydrogen as hydrogen is introduced to
the atmosphere it would react with the
carbon dioxide leading to the formation
of water introduce enough hydrogen and
you could eventually see Venus with 80%
of its surface covered in water for this
to work you'd need a lot of of hydrogen
so much that you'd probably need to find
a way to harvest it from a gas giant
like Jupiter or Saturn or maybe one of
their
moons yeah I'm not sure all this planet
moving and hydrogen bombarding was
really worth it you'd still be left with
only one goldilock planet capable of
supporting
[Music]
life
one day Mars could look like
[Music]
this allowing humans to comfortably live
on the planet all we'd need to do is to
terraform it but
how well we could nuke it
would dropping nukes on Mars make it
easier to live
there this is what if and here's what
would happen if we nuked
Mars believe it or not this is something
scientists have considered for
decades Elon Musk of SpaceX seems to
think that nuking Mars might be one of
the best and quickest options to make it
a place where humans could live the idea
is that we would explode thermonuclear
bombs in the sky over the planet's Two
Poles this would heat up the ice caps
and release carbon dioxide and water
from the poles then the greenhouse
effect would take place it would heat up
the whole planet making the surface more
habitable so this all sounds super quick
and easy why haven't we done this
yet it's because there's a high chance
that nuking Mars might not work out the
way we want it to too there are many
things that could go wrong with this
plan the first problem is it's all just
Theory and the theory could be wrong
that's because Mars has been losing its
atmosphere for a long time Earth's
atmosphere is almost 100 times thicker
than Mars is and if we're going to live
on Mars it needs a thicker atmosphere
some scientists think that we could
release CO2 from the North and South
poles and this could make Mars's
atmosphere more like Earth's but
a 2018 study published in nature
astronomy found that even if the nukes
are successful it would only increase
Mars's atmosphere to 7% of what Earth
has even if we create more carbon
dioxide in Mars's atmosphere it still
wouldn't be nearly enough to heat the
planet and the planet could seriously
use more heat since its current
temperature averages around -
63° and it would take decades for the
red planet to warm up even after it
gained the extra
CO2 So in theory this could delay humans
from ever landing on
Mars not only that but this assumes that
dropping thermonuclear bombs on the
planet would go perfectly keep in mind
these are nukes are the things that can
destroy entire
cities in fact the bombs we'd use on
Mars would be 1,000 times stronger than
the ones used in World War II if a bomb
exploded on the planet's surface instead
of up in the atmosphere some severe
damage would occur Not only would it
completely destroy parts of the planet's
surface it would also cause even more
radiation another thing that would delay
us from ever settling on Mars it's also
very likely that instead of warming Mars
a bomb could cause a nuclear winter this
could happen from the dust and particles
in the atmosphere caused by nuclear
explosions they'd almost entirely block
out the Sun causing Mars to cool down
even
more so nuking Mars probably isn't the
best idea it's one of Humanity's most
ambitious undertakings created to extend
human exploration to the farthest
reaches of our solar
system the next step in space
exploration isn't Generations away it's
happening right now and our destination
that mysterious and desolate world next
door
Mars imagine starting life over on that
tiny red dot over
265 million km
away what would happen if we built a
city on
Mars would you have to live
underground how many people would you
live
with and what would the Martian economy
look
like this is what if and here's what
would happen if we built a city on
Mars since
1975 the only things from Earth making
claims on Mars are robots and
satellites but now Elon Musk and his
company SpaceX are looking to change
that story their goal to create create a
city with a government trade and culture
on
Mars this plan involves 1,000 spaceships
and even more Brave new
recruits by surviving in lower gravity
with fewer people and only limited
supplies living on Mars might change how
we could adapt to dwindling resources on
Earth but with so much depending on the
early St stages of planning and Supply
runs could Life on Mars be
sustainable every great city starts
small whether you're talking about the
little fishing town of Hong Kong or a
Hut Village named Rome so if you want
this Martian colony to grow into a
thriving City you're going to need more
than a handful of people according to
the Bordeaux Institute National poly
technique you would need at least least
110 settlers to start this adventure the
SpaceX plan starts with two spaceships
carrying 100 people each with this
handful of explorers your city would
have just enough people to build more
habitats and research stations without
putting your resources in danger if you
run out of food at this stage that's the
end of the
experiment the biggest challenge this
city faces is becoming sustainable
without relying on regular shipments
from Earth which will only come every
few years you see with the egg-shaped
orbit of Mars it takes
687 Earth days to make one Martian year
Supply runs would only launch when Earth
and Mars align which happens every 2
years to cut down on travel time between
our worlds and after this nearly 8 month
long trip there's still a chance of
losing all those supplies when the
rocket lands since the gravity on Mars
is only 38 of the pull on Earth Landing
safely on the surface of Mars would be
dangerous and that doesn't take into
account the amount of dust flying in the
air after all the dust on the moon was
bad enough and it got into crew members
eyes and damaged systems on their
spacecraft but kick picking up the dust
on Mars might be even more deadly since
each grain is highly oxidized and
electrically charged but hey you made it
to Mars
safely now what are you going to
eat the chlorinated soils on Mars are
toxic and if you ingested them with your
food you might damage your thyroid gland
so that means farming is out outdoor
farming at least well before you worry
about eating you'll need to set up
protection from the harsh conditions on
Mars with an atmosphere made of 95%
carbon dioxide the air on Mars is toxic
and don't forget about the intense
radiation on the surface with more
exposure to radiation and no breathable
air you won't be able to survive without
a controlled environment thankfully with
the help of those rocks under your feet
you have all the the protection you need
just 5 m of the surface materials on
Mars called regolith provides the same
amount of shielding from radiation as
Earth's atmosphere this material would
be processed into cement to create
layered walls using robots and 3D
printers this material would be a
protective shell and underneath that
shell do science facilities Living
Spaces and all your home comforts
connected by tubes these domes would
provide you Shelter From the Raging dust
storms outside which might last for
months even with this technology Elon
Musk claims it could take up to 10 years
to establish a colony but it's during
this time that your quaint Martian
Village would grow into the first human
City beyond Earth since this world isn't
being drilled or fracked the power grid
on Mars can be made sustainable right
from the start we would set up solar
arrays for electricity and use natural
gases like methane for engines our
footprint on Mars could start low and
stay that way no matter how many people
live there and now you better figure out
a way to feed all these people the low
gravity on Mars might decrease your
muscle mass to keep your body healthy
you'll need to provide more protein
you'll have to serve the equivalent of
110 cooked chicken breasts and 660
carats every day if one of these domes
contained an indoor Farm you could raise
the chickens you need to feed your city
and you would have the most nutrient
Rich manure available if you used this
manure in the green houses you'd have a
way to fertilize your crops year round
but how could you irrigate the those
crops how would you get
water scientists still debate whether
liquid water exists below the ice caps
on Mars but if it does exist that
freshwater Source could be filtered for
the colonists to use for
irrigation with less gravity on Mars
pulling water down into the ground you
would need less water to keep your
plants alive than you would on Earth
since it would stay closer to the
surface
and with supplies being transported only
every 2 years having Spring Water
available on Mars would change how the
city would operate it would create a
government infrastructure to distribute
and oversee the water supply and employ
scientists to manage the filtration
needs now the city has an infrastructure
in place and jobs to fill so how would
you value your time in terms of cash how
could you pay for products or
Services cash weighs too much to travel
with in outer space and credit cards
would require Wi-Fi services
communicating back to Earth with a
14-minute gap in Communications between
Mars and Earth H you're going to need
something more locally
based well you might have to use a
cryptocurrency known as Mars coin but
you would have need to have bought it
with your Earth money before you boarded
the space spaceship while marscoin would
only be available to martians this money
would help build the government increase
trade and create a standard of living
with Society on Mars still new maybe you
could trade your services or learn to
barter Goods instead of relying on this
cash
system if we do things right Life on
Mars might be the model for future
civilizations free from the constraints
of the culture built on Earth or it
could be like every sci-fi movie ever
made thanks
Jupiter if you were to drill straight
down into Mars what would you
find would the red planet reveal its
true
colors would you finally Discover Life
on
Mars and how would drilling through Mars
compared to drilling on Earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we drilled through
Mars This is the jazero crater on Mars
and 3 and 1/2 billion years ago it
looked very different it used to be an
ancient river Delta that carried clay
minerals into the Crater Lake it might
have even hosted Martian
life fast forward to now and the jazero
crater has become a perfect Landing site
for NASA's shiny new Rover meet
perseverance if I were to search for
past life forms on Mars This Is The
Place I'd start looking too only instead
of collecting Rock samples I'd send a
Rover to drill through the
surface what's the worst that could
happen did you know that Mars has Mars
Quakes they're like earthquakes but on
Mars NASA's Martian Lander called
Insight detected 480 of these Mars
Quakes in 20120 alone luckily there
isn't much out there to damage for us
these Mars Quakes are a good thing they
create seismic waves that our scientists
can study and based on these studies
they can theorize about the Martian
interior but you and I would be doing
this the hard way we would drill through
Mars to see what Secrets it holds
inside if you started drilling through
the reddish iron oxide abundant surface
layer of Mars the first thing you'd
discover is that the interior is not so
red but don't be surprised in 2012 NASA
sent the Curiosity Rover to Mars it
landed about 3,700 km from the jazero
crater curiosity discovered that the
layer beneath the surface of Mars is
slate
blue yeah that's because it contains
high levels of silicon huh and as you
drill you should continue to expect the
unexpected the next Discovery you'd make
is that the crust layer on Mars is
thinner than the one on earth remember
Insight this little Lander indicated
that the Martian crust is only around 20
or 37 km thick compare that to the
Earth's crust which is approximately 40
to 50 km thick under the
continents if water still exists in
liquid form on Mars it could be several
kilometers inside this
crust and there are radioactive elements
in the liquid mantle below the crust
these elements release geothermal heat
through their decay
and it should be enough heat to melt
thick sheets of subsurface ice this
geothermal heat could be why there was
liquid water on Mars 4 billion years ago
even though the surface temperatures
were below
freezing but enough Theory let's keep
drilling boring through Mars would be
even harder than drilling through Earth
the deepest we've ever drilled on Earth
was was 12.2 km into its crust and that
came with high budget costs technical
difficulties and plenty of bad luck but
on Mars this would be an unimaginably
tricky Endeavor the Insight Lander tried
drilling but it encountered unexpected
soil properties the drill probe was
trying to go 5 m deep but could only go
a fraction of the distance before
popping out
then there was curiosity it experienced
a mechanical error the drill feed
mechanism That was supposed to move the
drill bit forward wasn't moving when
commanded luckily scientists designed a
new more human form of Martian drilling
now the Rover uses the force of its
robotic arm to push the drill bit into
the surface as it
spins but don't get your hopes High
about reach reaching the mantle of Mars
too soon it took curiosity the entire
day to drill a mere 5 cm hole based on
that going 5 km down would take up to
300 years and you'd need a bigger
drill there's still so much we have to
learn about Mars but maybe drilling
isn't the most effective way to do it
especially since we haven't gotten very
far far into the crust of our own Planet
congratulations you've taken the
seven-month long journey and have
finally landed on Mars and it turns out
you're the first person better start
cleaning the place up and getting it
ready for human
colonization will you ever make it back
to
Earth how will you gather resources for
survival and will this happen
someday this is what if and here's what
would happen happen if you were the
first person on Mars a trip to Mars
might happen sooner than you think NASA
is hoping for it to be as soon as
2033 think about that the first person
on Mars might be watching this video
right now hello future
Martian and NASA may not be the first to
get there there are plenty of other
space companies trying to get to Mars
around the same time similar to what we
saw in the 1960s with the moon it's very
likely that we'll see another space race
only to Mars this time but getting there
is the boring part now that you've
landed what happens
next your first goal will be to set up
base and it can't just be anywhere
researchers believe that the best place
for a camp on Mars is near the planet's
poles there you'll find massive ice
deposits which are thought to contain
large amounts of water we need water to
survive but it's heavy and it takes up a
lot of room on a spacecraft so to solve
this problem we could potentially turn
this ice into water that we could drink
study and use scientists suspect that
the ice deposits may also contain iron
and sulfur which could be used for
manufacturing in the future but that's
in the long term for now let's worry
about your base being built luckily you
won't be building it as space companies
intend to send a team of robots up there
to assemble the base for you after that
done you can finally move in the base
will be roughly 12 M high and 5 m in
diameter that may sound pretty roomy but
you won't be alone space companies are
planning to send six people to Mars for
the first expedition at least you'll
have people to talk to while you're
there once you've landed you'll quickly
notice how different Mars feels from
Earth Mars has just one third the
gravity that the Earth has NASA says
that a person who weighs 45 kg on Earth
would only weigh about 17 Kg on Mars
you'll be able to jump all around the
planet but if that's all you expect to
do this trip won't be for you the first
people on Mars will be unlike any
astronauts we've seen before apart from
knowing everything about physics and
spaceships they'll also have to be
farmers botanists and excellent problem
solvers one massive problem they'll all
need to solve food production let's hope
you like your vegetables because a aside
from astronaut food that's pretty much
all you'll be eating a university in the
Netherlands simulated crop growing on
Mars and found out that potatoes peas
carrots and radishes could all grow on
the planet you'll be able to use the
soil on Mars and water will come from
recycling urine and whatever other Water
Products were brought onto the planet
and speaking of human waste
unfortunately you'll have to use your
poop to fertilize the crops you're
growing now that's recycling
after about 9 months of researching
farming and exploring Mars you'll then
begin your journey home this is arguably
the hardest part of the trip you and
your crewm mates would hop into this
Mars Ascent vehicle or MAV for short
then you need to line it up perfectly
with the larger spaceship which is
orbiting Mars the ascent up to your
spaceship could last as little as under
a half an hour or it could be several
days it all depends on whether you can
line up the MAV with the larger
spaceship and if not done correctly
things could go very very bad but if all
goes according to plan think of what
you've just done you were the first
person on Mars and after living there
for months what you've learned will make
it easier for future generations to live
on the red planet
permanently did you know that Mars has
polarized C just like we do here on
Earth with the right technology they
might be our water source should we ever
move to the red planet but in their
current state these caps could be a
source for extreme interplanetary sport
want to ski on snow unlike anything else
in the universe want to test your skills
on the biggest mountain in the solar
system bring your 8 snowsuit if you must
just be sure to pack a good
helmet this is what if and here's what
would happen if you could ski on
Mars even though Mars is much smaller
and much colder than our planet its
abundance of water ice makes it a
compelling option for life on another
planet and with the concept of a future
Mars colony gaining popularity homes on
the red planet might soon be on the
market if we do end up living on Mars
someday what would we do for fun
technology will have advanced so
there'll be a lot on offer but what
about the classics like enjoying the
Great
Outdoors could we go skiing on
Mars lucky for you Mars is home to the
highest mountain in our solar system
Olympus Mons is a shield volcano that's
21,000 M tall that's more than four
times higher than the highest ski slopes
on Earth but if you call yourself a
black diamond devil then this isn't the
hill for you it turns out Olympus Mons
is more boring than the Bunny Hill it
has an average slope of just 5° and
considering that Martian gravity is just
1/3 of what we experience here on Earth
it might take you a while to get started
on the flip side because of that weak
gravity you could jump three times as
high so
this could be
this let's not get ahead of ourselves we
haven't even started moving yet with an
average temperature of -60° it's
definitely cold enough to snow on Mars
but considering its dry low press
atmosphere snow barely reaches the
surface and never stays for very long
that said Mars does have two poles that
consist of water ice and carbon dioxide
which in solid form is dry ice and at
Mars's South Pole there's a dry ice
deposit that's 1,000 M deep but before
you give it a go it's important to note
that the friction from your skis will
heat up the dry ice and turn it into a
gas causing you to lose
control if you really wanted to you
could try your luck on the water ice but
it's density brings it closer to the ice
skating conditions you'd find on Earth
so why use a flat ski when you could go
further with a sharp blade then again
there's more than one way to ski so if
you're that determined to make this work
then just slap on some hard wax and take
things cross country or is that cross
Planet whichever style you choose it's a
double-edged sword shorter and thinner
skis are your best bet for reaching fun
speeds but they're also going to have to
support your clunky space boots and if
you don't get the balance right well you
had a good
run Mars didn't always look like this it
may once have been covered in
oceans but what if we brought all the
Martian water back and transform the red
planet into one that's half blue
what would Mars look like if it was 50%
land and 50%
water where would we even find enough
water to fill Martian
oceans and why might we have no choice
but to Nuke the red
planet this is what if and here's what
would happen if Mars was half land and
half
water long ago Mars could have been
covered by a massive ocean and there may
have been Rivers streams and lakes
spreading out across the planet too it
might be that billions of years ago
Earth and Mars had similar
climates yeah except the Martian ocean
covered only 20% of the planet compared
to Earth's
71% and the surface temperature was a
bit cooler all of that thanks to an
atmosphere that didn't stick around long
enough 4 billion years ago Mars lost its
protective magnetic field and the solar
winds started to carry all of its
atmosphere off into
space a few hundred million years later
Mars changed from a warm wet world to
what we know it as today C and dry only
18% of its ocean remains trapped in
Frozen polar ice caps so if you wanted
to turn Mars into a half land half ocean
kind of planet you'd need to add a whole
lot of
water unlike Mars most of Earth is
covered with
oceans so what do you say we donate some
of that water to our red neighbor well
let me tell you that's a very very bad
idea to make Martian oceans as deep as
Earth's you'd need to ship out about 20%
of our ocean water and this would suck
for our marine life yeah leave the
Earth's oceans where they belong besides
there are a few other places in the
solar system where you could find water
like Saturn's moon Enceladus and
Jupiter's moon Europa they might have
twice as much water as Earth but to
transport some of that precious H2O
you'd need to move massive ice blocks
through
space ah this would be difficult to pull
off to say the least you'd need rockets
capable of transporting huge amounts of
weight and you'd need money yeah a lot
of it cuz the price could be as high as
$1,500 per kilogram
and considering how much water you'd
require well the final price tag for
this operation would be well into the
trillions yeah expensive I know but
there might be another way of bringing
Martian water back and you'll love this
one because it involves nukes yeah you
heard me right you're about to Nuke the
red planet and yes this would give it
some water how well all that energy
would release Frozen Martian carbon
dioxide this would cause temperatures to
climb and thaw out the poles it would be
kind of like causing controlled climate
change only you'd need to detonate
around 3500 nuclear bombs every day and
this would mean shipping twice as many
bombs daily as the United States
currently has in its entire
Arsenal that's an enormous amount of
radioactive material to release and it
wouldn't exactly make Mars
habitable plus you'd still need a lot
more water to cover half the planet in
oceans okay it seems like nuking
everything in sight isn't the best idea
maybe you should take a little planetary
history lesson instead about about 4
billion years ago during the late
bombardment period a Non-Stop barrage of
asteroids collided with Mars This
created enough water to eventually make
an ocean 300 M deep so all you'd need to
do is recreate this event
today you'd have to redirect at least a
million comets and meteors so that
they'd end up on a collision course with
Mars at as the Comets crashed into Mars
they'd burn up and release water vapor
rinse and repeat until you get enough
water to cover half the red
planet but where would this water
go well looking at Mars's topography
you'd find that all this new water would
settle mostly above its equator Mars
would have new land masses that would
look like continents there would even be
mountains sticking up on some parts of
the planet Olympus Mons the tallest
volcano in the solar system would now
Tower High out of Mars's new Northern
ocean but just because you were able to
bring enough water to cover half the
planet that wouldn't mean it would last
because of Mars's low atmospheric
pressure all this water would easily
boil
away well wait how would boil away if
water's boiling point is 100° C aha well
that's the boiling point on Earth on
Mars the water would start to boil at 0°
C Ah that's frustrating especially after
all the work you put in bringing all
this water to Mars you'd have to hope
that this water vapor would work as a
greenhouse gas if it could trap enough
heat in the Martian Atmos osphere and
turn Mars into a lush terraformed world
maybe then you'd be lucky enough to be
the only Earthling ever to go for a swim
on another
planet scientists theorize that many
millions of years ago Mars had Rings
just like Saturn and it looks like the
red planet could be due for a new set of
rings in the
future how EX exactly would this
happen would these Rings clutter up
Martian
orbit and how soon would these new Rings
start raining down on
Mars This is what if and here's what
would happen if Mars had Rings like
Saturn the four gas giants in our Solar
System Jupiter Uranus Neptune and Saturn
all have ring systems surrounding them
of those Saturn has the largest and Mars
could join the club scientists studying
Martian moons Phobos and deos suggest
that Mars could have had several more
moons including one up to 20 times
larger than
Phobos over billions of years these
moons could have been destroyed and
become part of an ancient ring system
could Phobos and deos be next on the
Martian Moon chopping
block Phobos is orbiting Mars only about
6,000 km from the planet's surface and
it's slowly losing altitude eventually
it will reach the RO limit this is the
closest a big space body can come to a
planet and still be held together by its
gravitational forces for Phobos the
estimated Ro limit is
5,470 km from Mars at this point the
tidal forces of Mars would start to pull
the moon apart after breaking into
carbonaceous condite meteorites the
Stony rocks and dust would form a thin
dark ring around the planet you'd find
that the smaller Martian Moon deos would
still exist that's because it orbits
Mars from a comfortable
[Music]
won't get ripped apart into rings for
about 50 million years the development
of rings around the red planet would be
a challenge for space flights it would
be difficult to navigate or transport
people in
resources even the most routine trips on
or off Mars would become hazardous
rides and a ring system would block some
sunlight having huge effects on our
human settlements on the surface Mars is
already a frozen planet with an average
surface temperature of -
63° so things would get even colder
let's hope your descendants brought
enough warm space
suits and even more danger would lie
ahead eventually all the objects in the
ring would come crashing down on
Mars big rocks would leave massive of
new craters on the planet's
surface if it's anything like what
happens on Saturn Martian settlers could
face massive storms of rock and dust
falling to the surface at 10,000 kg per
second the future of humanity would
depend on our ability to create new
technologies to blast apart these
falling objects before they crush
us luckily for us this would happen
sometime between 1 million and 100
million years after the ring forms yeah
we'd have plenty of time to come up with
a solution maybe we could just nuke all
those space rocks before they Crush our
Martian
Dream well that's a story for another
what
[Music]
if
martians might really exist in the
future but instead of the aliens of
sci-fi movies martians would be humans
born and raised on Mars